ce qu'on va faire on va essayer de faire
un petit bac ensemble d'accords par
ailleurs
voilà je vais vous dire attention c'est
parti on démarre à l'e.coli à chaque
fois vous donner de mauvaises réponses
vous êtes éliminés on va chercher en
paix le mot que vous utilisez le plus en
paix on démarre tranquille en paix
genève les allées badioli publique
directe le mot excuse publique chantal
armand p funk et l'y attend
patate marc-antoine aux pommes de terre
alors patate pommes de terre
marc-antoine ce n'était pas bon a ses
limites
c'est l'aîné et au lieu de ses limites
et philippe lellouche obtus temps
brüderle de plus on peut pareillement
pareillement aux lignes bah ouais ouais
ouais pulluler mais non non c'est fini
chantal pourquoi pas pourquoi on aime ou
pas mais papa tu attends pas pas bien
joué philippe souffle plouffe bouder
foot ou poutou par chantal un peu le
rôle des das névés revanche [ __ ]
merci et 10 4 tandis qu l'air pas mal
philippe pétales pétales bouder police
au total il vient dit il il les lui là
d'accord je ne comprends pas qu'on prend
parti je l'apprends pas à s'arrêter et
lee réparation tu as des hémorroïdes et
le bien que dans la vraie vie
préface vous donnez pas nous parmentier
par matteo est c'est vrai que dans la
vraie vie la raison est l hécatombe
gagner on a deux perdants c'est au lit
et marque d'attention ces attentions en
j 1 prénom rebut ou des rougis après
nombreux week-ends
elie janelle jamais l'on marc-antoine
wall e là comme ça c'est chaud il est
gênant holy va mieux
bizarre jamie hince avait déjà mis
d'accord récemment chantal jasmin
pas mal elif g1000 un très bien philippe
et isabelle ouais ça pas bouder j bourg
on la disait mais ouais ouais djadja jaz
un ont osé mais aussi au fait petite
lettre z en sait quelque chose que
chantal voit rarement en z
allons-y je commençais f
az un zèbre ou marc antoine gvt et
a berné merki elie 12
on arrête là c'est vrai qu'au talent les
hoops une catatrophe gelé chéri e en
1ère l attention maintenant il va il va
falloir trouver direct d'accord c'est
pas un tour de table on air elle peut
être au beurre sur le côté ou du mas au
1er à claix arts et lettres
la raie bien joué mais il pleut louche
on peut vite chaîne en b celle de rocco
siffredi est assez longue
michelin 210 pas d'avis et la biographie
la biographie en paix un adjectif pour
la carrière d'elie semoun au prospère
optionnel parfait y'avait parfaite
propre rouge de laâyoune
voilà pour la gêne ou de séries bah oui
ça fait plaisir en est ce une insulte
bien vingaard saperlipopette jason est
pire
o o à une personne avec qui vous
aimeriez bien faire l'amour en général
quelqu'un de connu quelques de connaître
les habitats ary abittan bons soins
thalasso web angelina jolie angelina
jolie elie semoun en gpo mais marrant
toi tu as a new day la caméra quoi
qu'est ce que tu as qu'est ce que t'as
chantal pourquoi j'ai créé des caméras